التعديلات القضائيه وما تبعها من تظاهرات
تمثل خطرا كبيرا على الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي
قد يؤدي الى تشديد الاوضاع الماليه واعاقه
الاستثمار والنمو على المدى الطويل وهكذا
يرى صندوق النقد الدولي الوضع في تل ابيب
وجاء اقرار الميزانيه ليزيد منه صحيفه ذي
ماركر الاقتصاديه الاسرائيليه وصفته بحكم
الاعدام على الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي هل هذا
وصف مبالغ فيه لا يبدل الامر كذلك فوكاله
موديز الشهر الماضي خفض التوقعات التصنيف
الائتماني السيادي لاسرائيل من ايجابي الى
مستقر كما ان التوقعات تشير الى ان نمو
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي لاسرائيل سيتباطى
الى
2.5% في 2023 مقارنه ب
6.5% في 2022
[موسيقى]
ووصى كل هذه التحذيرات ياتي تقرير اخر
ليزيد الانتقادات الموجهه لحكومه نتنياهو
رئيس الوزراء انفقه على منزله حينما شغل
المنصب من قبل اضعاف انفاق رئيسي الوزراء
السابقين
بنات مجتمعين خلال نفس المده هذا التقرير
صادر من مكتب رئاسه الوزراء بناء على طلب
حركه حريات المعلومات في اسرائيل والتي
تاسست عفوا عام 2004 من قبل حقوقيين
وقانونيين وبحسب التقرير انفق بنت الذي
تولى رئاسه الوزراء في الفتره من يونيو
2021 وحتى يونيو 2022 ولقيد الذي تولى
بعده المنصب في الفتره من يوليو وحتى
ديسمبر عام 2022 انفق اقل من مليون شيكل
اي نحو 285 الف دولار في عام واحد بينما
زادت نفقات نتنياهو عن اربعه ملايين شيكل
مليون ومئه الف دولار خلال السنه الواحده
ورغم ان ارقامه اقل منه لكن بنات نفسه كان
قد تعرض لانتقادات حينما كان رئيسا
للوزراء بسبب هذه النفقات التي تتحملها
الدوله يخرج وقتها ويعلن انه سيدفع فاتوره
طعام عائلته من جيبه الخاص
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات